The Joe Rogan experience and I never got the rubber boots.
You know what I mean?
I was always just like had sneakers.
I'd be like trying to get,
trying to get the Fallon at like seven in the morning,
walking to the subway through the slush.
It was like,
it would be beautiful while it was snowing and then as soon as on the ground you
were just like,
get rid of this shit.
Now did you write for Fallon?
[inaudible] what was that kid like?
I mean it was,
uh,
it was frustrating.
They didn't like,
because I started when he started late night with Jimmy Fallon,
I was one of the first guys there and they didn't like any of my jokes.
Like it was just,
it was,
it was impossible to mean or just like this is going to make Jimmy unlikable.
Like it wasn't about being funny so much as like coming off as smart and uh,
and friendly,
you know,
and likable that they,
that's what I was there for a year and then they barely used anything I ever
did,
but they knew I was funny.
They liked me and I thought for some reason in my head,
I thought that if I quit before a year,
that it'll like follow me.
People were like,
what happened with Fallon?
Why were you only there a year that like,
and then when I left,
it was like no one would have given a shit if I had left after 10 weeks,
you know,
it wouldn't have mattered at all.
Yeah,
it was good.
It's an interesting experience,
but I did not enjoy it.
Being a writer for other people's voices has gotta be very difficult.
It's,
I mean,
for me it's impossible.
It's like I write in my voice and you either like it or you don't.
Like I've written for Jimmy Kimmel,
Sarah Silverman,
and then if I love to joke,
they loved it too.
Uh,
but with Fallon,
that was not the case.
You know,
it was,
he was,
it was almost never like he might,
he might,
he would laugh at the joke,
but he be like,
I can't say this.
I can't do it.
What are they trying to do?
Like what,
what does he try to do?
And he's trying to be like Middle America,
like there's a market for that.
Right.
Is that what it is?
He just wants everyone to love him,
you know,
he just wants everyone to,
uh,
everyone to love him.
And that's like not a bad trait to have in a late night host.
Right.
Probably the best trait to having a late night host.
[inaudible] I'd like to see him drunk one day.
Just shitting on everybody though.
I think it'd be hilarious slurs.
Does it do that?
Oh yeah.
Cause I mean,
I,
I've,
I've heard that he quit drinking.
I don't know if that's true,
but he would like,
he liked to get drunk and like,
and like shitty bars and like hang out,
like with the,
with the staff and the crew,
like he was,
he's like a man of the people and he didn't just want to go home and drink.
He wanted to go out and go to some weird bar that was like in a subway that no
one knew about and have beers.
Like he was,
uh,
he was like a fun drunk,
you know.
But he did a lot.
Yeah.
There was always those rumors that he's got a problem.
She found it's got a problem.
Yeah.
Do you think that's like the pressure of just being this like super friendly,
sweet guy on TV wanting everybody to love you?
Then you're like,
oh my God,
get me a fucking drank so I can cut loose.
I'm,
I think that could be part of it,
you know?
That's why I was,
I was thought like with my persona,
like let's be the meanest person you can so that you can,
it allows you to be nice off stage.
You know,
you guys,
you kind of,
it gives you a little bit of distance,
but the guys who come off as like your best friend onstage tend to be monsters
off stay.
Some of them,
man.
Yeah.
I got another story.
I'll tell you when you get off the air about one of those.
Great.
Okay.